if you're an architect student and have
an iPad laying around I'm going to share
with you a little secret download the
more folio trace app right now portfolio
Trace can integrate your life so simply
and so easily that I use it every single
day as a qualified architect first of
all the stencils feature makes even
novices who can't draw like me seem like
they can actually draw whereas a
two-finger tap to undo becomes so
ingrained in your native actions that
you're going to find yourself tapping
with two fingers even when you're not on
the iPad the one thing I genuinely hated
carrying around is a scale ruler at
University because all the time you're
flipping the ruler around trying to
understand what scale was whereas with
more folio you can quickly scale any
single drawing and then use a scale
ruler which immediately scales to that
scale so you don't have to worry about
is it 150 one to 100 want to who knows
what you can quickly and easily figure
it out so more folio Trace will
genuinely make your life so much easier